news daily from science mission although
cell migration plays a central role in
development and disease the underlying
molecular mechanism is not fully
understood author supporting nature
communications that activation of growth
factor receptors lead to phosphorylation
of 10 s3 and p10 which triggers
rearrangement of the TNS 3 dlc 1 and p10
pi3k complexes in 210 s3 pi3k and pete
and dlc one complexes subsequently 10 s3
pi3k complex translocates to the leading
edge of a migrating cell to promote
track 1 activation whereas pete and dlc
one translocates to the posterior for
localized story activation next
molecular mechanisms underlying tumor
metastasis is incompletely defined
authors in the journal Cell identified
DNA repair kinase dna-pk sees as a
master driver of pro metastatic
signaling and tumor metastasis through
transcriptional regulation preclinical
findings are strongly supported by
clinical observations that demonstrate
that DNA p cases is significantly
upregulated in advanced disease and
predicts for tumor metastasis recurrence
and poor survival DN efficacies was
shown to be highly activated in
metastatic tumors independent of DNA
damage indicators these findings
nominate dna-pk sees as a therapeutic
target to suppress metastasis for more
news visitors at www scenes mission calm
or science mission facebook page thanks
for what